Okay.
Welcome to part four of the complete guide
to InfluxDB two.
In this tutorial, we're gonna be taking a
look at collecting metrics with Telegraph.
Telegraph is one of my most favoritest tools
ever
because it has just such
extensive
support
for collecting metrics
from anywhere, and I mean almost
anywhere.
I've given many talks on Telegraph over the
years, specifically around cloud native architectures and patterns
for scaling your metric collection pipeline.
I will be giving that lecture on this
course again with some new details
and tips,
so stay tuned for that. Today, we want
to understand how to start collecting metrics with
Telegraph.
Here is our InfluxDB that we have set
up previously,
and we are not collecting any metrics.
We have the buckets that we created on
the last tutorial,
but that's it.
Now we can jump over to our Telegraph
configuration here and we'll just delete the one
that we created when we were experimenting.
We'll do that again. We're going to create
a system one, we're going to store it
for one hour and we're going to click
continue.
We will name this system
monitoring,
some good
description,
and we will click create.
Now, what we're to do this time is
copy this to the clipboard
and export it,
and copy this
and run it.
So what we're doing here is exporting our
Influx token, which I now see that is
slightly covered by the header, but that's okay.
We're using something in Telegraph that's relatively new,
which is the remote configuration
and that you can actually store your Telegraph
TOML files as GitHub guests
on static site hosts like S3, GCS, Netlify,
any of these things,
and just tell Telegraph to consume them, provided
they're in a public endpoint or something that
you have secured locally.
There's also options for providing authentication for these
endpoints, but we won't be covering that today.
So we can hit return
and our Telegraph has started.
And what we should see,
hopefully, in around ten seconds time,
that it begins to write metrics to our
InfluxDB
instance.
Now some useful output from Telegraph when you
get started is the loaded inputs.
Really, you want to ensure that the plugins
that you have enabled appear here.
We're not using aggregators or processors, although we
will have tutorials on them later,
and we are writing our data to InfluxDB
v2.
And if we pop over here and say
listen for data,
we'll see connection found.
So it looks like everything is working just
as expected.
We can click on one hour and now
we see our measurements showing up in
our InfluxDB.
We'll change the window to five minutes and
we can see we have this nice steady
line for the usage
guest.
And if we take a look at network,
it may be a bit more active,
perhaps not, but that's okay. And we can
start to see those metrics coming in now,
and of course my face is covering up
the most useful bit.
Now,
configuring and working with Telegraph is really
simple, straightforward, trivial. You just have to configure
it a couple of times to really get
to grips with what you're doing.
So we're to make a few changes to
our Telegraph config.
We're going to come to here, we're going
to click on it, and this allows us
to copy and paste
the whole thing.
Like so.
So there's a fair amount of comments,
but you'll see here that we have the
agent configuration block, which is denoted here by
a single square parens.
We can configure the interval at which we
wish to collect our metrics.
We can set the round interval.
This is great when you have Telegraph running
across multiple nodes in your infrastructure and you
want the time alignment on your metrics to
work.
So that means that if you have your
interval set ten seconds, as the example here
is kind of showing us,
that every point that will be written to
our InfluxDB
will be on the hour with zero seconds,
ten seconds, twenty seconds, thirty seconds, forty seconds,
fifty seconds, and then back to zero.
Just means you don't have to do any
juggling
if the telegraphs are not all started up
precisely at the same time across your machines.
Now, two of my
favorite flags the Telegraph config are the metric
batch size and the metric buffer limit.
This is how you get
your resiliency
when you are collecting metrics with Telegraph.
The metric batch size,
Telegraph will attempt to collect that many metrics
and write them to the output so that
you're not writing a single metric with every
request.
It's going to increase the throughput and performance
of your Telegraph agent.
The metric buffer limit is there in case
your output should happen to be down or
throw in errors. If your database is down
and Telegraph cannot write to it, it's going
to hold up to 10,000 points in memory
and drop the oldest
if it comes to that.
You can set this to whatever value you
want. You really need to understand how important
your metrics are and how much memory you
have available for this telegraph to be able
to store those in memory if required.
We have a collection jitter. This is a
parameter which allows each of the Telegraph plugins
to stagger the request that they make to
the system for metrics.
You don't normally want to have ten, twenty,
30, a hundred, a thousand telegraph agents collecting
metrics from similar endpoints or similar systems
and all hitting them at the same time.
So we can jitter the collection just to
avoid things like that.
The flush interval allows us to see how
often we should write to our output. We
have a collection interval and then a flush
interval,
and we can
jitter the flush as well. So if you
do happen to have a hundred telegraphs running
on a hundred machines, all right into a
single database, you don't want them all to
land at the exact same millisecond,
potentially bad. So you can use a jitter
to stack with that too.
Okay.
Precision.
You can tell Telegraph to
store higher resolution metrics
by storing the timestamp of collection in nanoseconds,
milliseconds, microseconds, or seconds.
Debug is the first thing we're going to
change today, and we're going to enable that
to true so that we can understand what
is happening when we run Telegraph.
No.
Omet hostname is a flag that is entirely
optional, and I want to talk about it
right now. So
if you're running Telegraph in an ephemeral environment
where maybe it's containers, maybe it's Kubernetes,
then storing the host name of where Telegraph
runs may not be that important to your
overall metric strategy.
However, in more traditional environments where you look
after your infrastructure and you take care of
each of those machines, then understanding
the host name may be important.
So if you're collecting
operating
system level metrics,
yes, keep the host name there.
If you're running an ephemeral environment as containers,
probably best to just admit that you don't
really want the pod name or container name
to be available as a host name. It
doesn't make a lot of sense there.
Okay,
now we're going to leave our output configured,
but we're going to leverage something else that
is very cool about Telegraph and that you
can actually write your metrics to multiple locations.
So as well as writing to InfluxDB two,
we want to understand what these metrics look
like so we can see them in our
system. Maybe we're doing some sort of experimentation,
testing, or debugging,
and we can just say, write these files
to standard out.
So we're gonna have live feedback from Tenograph
as it attempts, or as it is collecting
these metrics. We'll sell right onto InfluxDB two.
What I see a lot of people doing
is trying to InfluxDB two and InfluxDB one
and maybe Thanos and maybe M3.
You you may just be experimenting with what
back end store you need for your metrics
and that's okay. Telegraph can just hook in
there and work with anything.
We're not going go over the inputs, they're
all mostly self explanatory.
What I will show you is how to
understand the inputs that are available and how
to configure them.
The best thing you can do is go
to the Telegraph repository.
That's github.com/influxdata/telegraph.
From here, you can click on plugins.
You will see inputs and outputs. Those are
the two that you will use the most
with inputs
being the one that you wanna be, maybe
you're perhaps more curious about and want to
understand.
You can scroll up and down this and
you'll see all of the systems that Telegraph
knows how
to fetch metrics from.
What we'll do is we will go to
Prometheus.
We will click on this. We want to
be able to collect some Prometheus metrics.
You can see an example from the configuration
of how to enable it.
If there are any optional flags, they're all
available here and we can uncomment them or
copy and paste the code that we need
for the configuration.
At the bottom of every readme for these
plugins is an example of the output too.
We'll see here, these are the metrics that
are going to emitted
by
this plugin.
We'll add one more metric
to our configuration.
And I have a Prometheus running on my
local machine, and hopefully, we should see some
metrics come from here.
So now we're just going to run Telegraph
like we did before, but instead of a
remote configuration, we are going to use the
telegraph.com
that we have just edited and saved on
our machine.
We will hit return, and within a few
seconds, we should start to see one extra
debug output, which we already have here,
and the output fail plugin, which is going
to spit a whole bunch of metrics, like
so to our terminal.
This allows us to confirm that we're seeing
what we expect to see.
Now we can jump over to here, click
cancel on this and explore,
And now we have more metrics and measurements
available inside of our OneAir bucket.
You can see the Prometheus style ones all
start with go underscore
because it's using the Go runtime to understand
that Prometheus is healthy.
There's some Prometheus specific ones below here.
So we have configured Telegraph.
We understand some of the agent configuration to
change the interval, the flush interval, the batch
and buffering,
as well as any jitter that may be
needed for our environment.
We know how to use the Telegraph GitHub
page to find new plugins and understand our
configuration and output.
And we can run Telegraph with remote configurations
or local configurations to get metrics written to
our InfluxDB.
So, I hope that helps. We'll be doing
more.
much more with Telegraph
throughout this course, and I look forward to
sharing it with you more. Have a great
day.